the phillies will hand the baseball to
left-hander matt moore
moore looking for his first win of the
season as well
let's find out what paul deyoung can do
as the shortstop is hitting fifth in the
lineup
he had a one-for-three game with a
strikeout last night
and more checks second the left-hander
kicks the pitch
swung on and sky to right center field
on the run quinn nearing the alley he's
there he's got it
and matt moore does get out of the first
unscathed
he threw 16 pitches only five of them
strikes but the cardinals do not score
no runs no hits and two left will go to
the bottom of the first
now for the cardinals it will be
left-hander kwang young kim
kim is making his first start for the
cardinals here in 2021 he's coming off a
back injury
well given that uh alec ball has had
some struggles on pitches inside from
lefties and that kim has had so much
success there you would sort of surmise
maybe this isn't the best matchup for
alec but we'll see
alec overall hitting 234 with a homer
and five runs batted in he went one for
four last night
you know one hit was a ball hit to deep
short that
young fielded but slipped as he went to
throw
off the hands looped in the left center
field of base in rounding third heading
for ole miss hoskins
the throw by dean is cut off they throw
back to second
it's one nothing phillies rbi single
alec bow
so the bases are loaded for matt joyce
coming up here 3-2 pitch
and he struck him out here's dylan
carlson
ground ball to first nice play on the
glove side by hoskins and matt moore is
there to cover
in time 3-1 on the put out
matt looked like he had his angle john
to cover that bag and then he looked
back
and it kind of knocked him off balance a
little bit i think he should get two
outs for that he tagged him and then
stepped on firm
molina struck out his first time up
and molina hits it out to deep left
field
at the wall gone three
run homer yadier molina
and the cardinals go on top 3-1
on yachty's third of the year
and that brings in paul deyoung and a
young
center field at the wall
back to back dead center
and the home run for the young his third
and the cardinals go
back to back in the third
here's dylan carlson austin dean the
runner at first he'll be moving on the
3-2
pitch and there he goes and the pitch is
hit towards left field sinking line
drive that's down
into the left field corner mccutcheon
runs it down dean was running on the
pitch
he's going to score it's 5-1 cardinals
as dylan carlson delivers a double
they'll deal with the pitcher kim
swinging a ground ball left side that's
handled on the backhand by boehm low
throw and it gets away from the
first baseman and the cardinals pick up
another run
as kim was hustling all the way here's
tommy edmond
oh and two the count the pitch
ground ball hit towards short dd charges
gloves it flips to segura
sides retire but six runs across for
saint louis yada yada molina and paul de
ungo back to back
and the redbirds chase matt moore from
today's ball game we're going to the
bottom of the third
so now jt romuto jt was hit by a pitch
his first time
up outfield plays him straight away
carlson pretty deep in center
two and two here's the pitch swing and a
little number off the end of the bat
first base line molina out to get it
he'll flip it to first and seguro will
read it and come home
and kind of works like a safety squeeze
as uh the phillies do get a run back
it's now six to two down to third goes
hoskins
kim the 1-2 pitch swung on and sky to
left
coming on for it is dean settling under
it he'll make the catch hoskins tagging
he's coming home the throw is nowhere
near in time
racial scores standing up out of calm
does get the runner home
and it's now a six to three cardinal
league all right
so joyce at the plate very pro type
hitter
always been a good hitter from the left
side three hits in the inning
five so far allowed by kim
billy's actually about hit the cardinals
5-4
there it is again the pitch
will bring up nolan aronado
and arenado hits it down the left field
line
and that ball is fair and gone
home run nolan oronato
his fourth of the year and the third
home run
hit by the cardinals today
went down to get it and picks up number
four
he has driven in 10 this year here's
yachty
romero working from the stretch deliver
is that balls hit hard
down the left field line is it fair
you bet it is back to back again
this time it's arenado and molina
last time it was molina and the young
and the cardinals have hit four home
runs in this game
and it's now 9-3 and it looks like it's
going to be matt carpenter to pinch it
2-2 pitch to him swinging a miss and
struck him out
well the side is finally retired
cardinals get three more and again
back-to-back homers for the second
inning in a row this time aronado and
molina he's got a two-homer game we're
going to the bottom of the fourth
cardinals nine in the phillies three
gregorius coming up here with a man on
it first and two down
that one's hit well out to right field
williams going back toward the
scoreboard he jumps it's off the top of
the wall
rounding third heading for home is
hoskins go and the second is d.d
gregorius
it's a 9-4 game there's
matt joyce three and two two outs the
pitch
popped up and this is on the infield
webb the pitcher takes it right in front
of the mound
you know he dropped that one justin
williams with
a walk and a hit he has a strikeout
today one for two
the cardinals sendowski into the
on deck circle the pitch
swinging a bouncer back to his amount
speared by hale coming home there's one
throw down to first
in time for the double play
one two three and a big out there as
david hale
starts it and the phillies turn to wow
terrific well that'll bring up rhys
hoskins who's had a big day today at the
plate he's three for three
and lilies could use a big two out hit
here to
try to claw their way back into this
game they're down nine to four
and the check swing he went
it's a strikeout for jordan hicks
so that'll bring up didi gregorius three
and two
two down mccutcheon at third torreyus at
second realmuto at first the runners
lead there they go the pitch is swung on
a deep fly ball to right field backing
up carlson he makes the catch on the
warning track for a red bird winner